[Music]
all right welcome back just lovers
hopefully you were just watching the
other segments that we have
on how there is a whooped magnus that
was not the official name
but yeah that was a very fun
uh game to watch the end game was so
weird because you know
usually when magnus says advantage
magnus gets the job done
but in this situation he did not he blew
that advantage
right out of the park like that was
under my sentence actually
and so yeah that was a very bad game for
magnus it was the first round so
hopefully you can sleep at night sorry
magnus and
this one is going to be seeing how um
our onion is going to whoop verus jump
uh so i realized white in this game and
in the game that we just watched this is
the same tournament
that was just the first round this is a
few rounds after that i think it was a
sixth round but please do it correct me
if i'm
wrong on which round this was uh anyways
so in this game
again others have pre played vienna but
i think he had lost the element of
surprise
so that could have had some hand in him
not winning well not really doing as
well as he did
at this in the opening segment of it uh
compared to the game that he played
against magnus
and so here uh arnhem played it
differently
which i think is kind of cool uh
do you see any cool ideas right right
out of the bat here
can black create some issues
for whites right now because the
previous game was bishop c5 you
mentioned that we also like the bishop
b4 ideas
so
what do you think anything else besides
those
yeah mr breaks yeah you're correct
knight e4 is something to consider but
i would not suggest knight e4 if you do
not play it frequently you got to know
what's going on in the opening so 94
and taking of its d5 and black already
gets a little initiative so
yeah careful with that
even if you play f5s or such it's not
going to be as
interesting i mean black already is
better
even f5 is good even if you don't want
to play f5 bishop d6 is another good one
and your bishop c5 like black already
has momentum very good
so that's one thing to keep in mind i
wanted to mention
just super quick right now
because in the last game it was also
knight f6 but i mentioned that knight c6
is doable too
this is like mid um like
20 12 13 14 15
these g3 ideas were so common and it was
so
bothersome because like as black i
couldn't really figure out how to play
so i instead of playing knight f6 i
switched to knight c6
so when you would play g3 i wouldn't
have my knight on f6
so um i could just you know delay this
knight
development and i would just go for h5
and it's funny because
um one of the games that i'm very proud
of
i was like barely 200 still not even w
i am that's like 2014 yeah and
i was playing against mamadou which is
like azerbaijani grandmaster 2650 plus
very strong and i drew with this as
black
and it was very funny because it was the
first round and i could see that he was
underestimating me because every move he
would like
he would make the move go out smoke
watch other games and like
spend 10 minutes and he would come back
sit make a quick move and i was like all
right so let's see you
let's see how you play when you're
really busted and the game ended the
draw
but i had an advantage but that was on
the point the point was like
i i had a uh because it was so popular
i knew that if he wanted to beat easy a
little girl with like 400 less rating
point
that's what he would play because i i
got the chance to prepare a little
before the game like just 10 minutes i
just checked some quick games
and um so that's what i decided i
remember i was looking and like magnus
had played a bunch of these from white
and black too
back in 2014 so i just wanted to kind of
mention that
in vienna this idea this idea also
exists
so make sure to think of that too
so g6 why wouldn't you want to play h5
uh after g3 um you can
but with knight c6 when g3 h5 this kind
of makes it a little bit more strong
just a little bit and i remember that's
later on uh like there were so many
other games that
uh was played and like sometimes you
want to just get this knight to e7 then
g6
this is another weakness because if this
happens this f4 is a good square for you
to
jump into yeah so
yeah keep that in mind just make sure
you have your repertoire
on g3 ideas as well so knight of six
there that
and queen h5 was played so after queen
h5
black ate a pawn but what now
we are going to give it back right so
what do you think black should do
not g6 i agree with that
sorry queen f6 maybe
but even if you do this queen f6 uh
i see what you're going for
well i guess
well queen f6 i think
what do you do after this yeah
yeah you kind of lose your d5 ideas
all right so
we gotta we gotta figure out how to
protect all these threats
so my knight could defend the f7 so
let's go for that first
that's the most important one bishop b3
now we're not going to be taking too
much time on defending this pawn i mean
yes they can definitely do knight c6
but then this this is going to be a very
very big problem because your knight is
super overloaded
and um we this knight can't hold your
whole position together so
we should develop but at the same time
we should develop so that we can cast
those so bishop v7 is what to do
but it's like imagine in the game you
play this knight d4 and you don't know
what to do after queen and swipe so you
got to know your theory
to some extent all right so knight d6
bishop moves bishop e7 bam finally
castle
now this is a quite a i want to say
equal but
both both players have equal chances
nobody's right now better
nobody has like a crazy idea coming up
it's just about developing
and kicking queens so now how can i try
to get my bishop out
because that's a big problem right
i mean maybe knight e8 if not 98 maybe
b6
so 98 makes sense i agree but do we want
to do it right away or can we try to
poke around a little bit more
uh violeta moving the b pawn like sounds
like b5
or b6 are also doable and quite
interesting i agree
also i agree uh we should be careful on
this bishop of sevens early on to jet
can't draw our king out so that's
another reason to know your openings
because if you know your openings you
know okay so that's a bad move so i
don't need to really worry about it
knight a5 looks like a wasted why
because bishop
i guess e5 and then you move then you
can move this knight and then you can
try to poke the bishop better
yeah i mean i was looking at c6
immediately but i also agree if you
don't know the theory
it's highly unlikely that you're gonna
choose knight a5
b6 makes sense 98 makes sense these are
the moves that make sense so
i think those are more
human moves rather than something like
knight a5 knight a5 is
um still very doable there's nothing
wrong with it but it just feels
unnatural so knight a5 bishop d5
and this was played and i think it's
kind of funny
because now irizo went for bishop f3
and levon played bishop b4 and here
elias did the novelty
he did d5 so
how do we feel about this
this d5 good bad
and i'm gonna take is take a second to
show you the a3 line
that is kind of funny because alireza
had played the exact same thing
against levon on a tournament on
chess.com
last year so i think it's kind of funny
that
he keeps repeating his um
openings very bold
yeah so this was something that happened
and aliza ended up winning this game as
white
so this wasn't the first encounter that
they had
in this line so it makes sense for
eliriza to have improvised and played
this novelty with d5 when you're on such
high level chess
you gotta surprise your opponents in the
opening as much as you can
so the five has a very clear threat
basically idea is also preventing black
from playing d5
yes in the last game he won against
uh well yeah yeah i don't know it wasn't
the exact same line but yeah
it was a lot of prevention too so this
does make sense d5
kind of already blocks your chances
makes you a little unhappy
that's what chess is about making your
opponent unhappy
i need some quotes all right so d5 what
now
what do you think black should do shall
we take it over here
yeah probably probably
in play d6 maybe
playing d6 maybe well i mean taking and
then
i i agree but
d6 or b6 so we should let's get rid of
this first and then
how should we get the special mass b6 or
d6
well b6 what after d6 if white plays d6
i guess just bishop b7 you just take
everything
[Music]
oh
yeah i guess after bishop e6 you get d6
and then bishop b7
and then well
there is a one very interesting line
here bishop b7 is fine but there is
something even better than that
c6 is also fine but we want something
stronger
the fact that this king is uncasted
should be winking
at you
so any any wings
yeah bishop basics
well i don't want you to castle and if
you take it i'll just take
take with the queen and now my queen is
also going to inflict some pain
if not the night's coming up it's the
momentum
the initiative momentum all these little
fun
big words
might be really hard to decide over the
board though so
yeah power of bishops
rapid yeah sure time control
so yeah d6 would not work and others
didn't do it he just developed
like a normal move
and castle 96
is very tempting i really like it uh he
went for queen f6
uh i can't tell you why
because both of them seem to be good
enough maybe perhaps queen f6 if take
take now it's black is better
just because little little better
just because there are so many weak
pawns black's pieces are more
coordinated
blackhand gets pieces more in
better position faster black can get
more pieces in better positions faster
there you go
well playing queen f6 um lets you
develop the knight while getting rid of
your less active queen
and it's also making threats along that
diagonal yeah
knight d6 puts the knights in a very
good position c4 square is mine
and it's also makes sense i want to do
rookie but then you don't know what to
do with your queen so i i i agree coin
f6
makes more sense at the end of the day
now queen a4
attacking pawn oh there's a threat of i
guess bishop takes
e2 maybe
not not at the moment so let me let me
try to poke your brain
is this a real threat
is queen d7 really threat or it's more
like a
get your rook in the game because
right uh yeah kind of gives you the
the temple loses the temple yeah um
mr briggs master beaks whoa whoa
okay makes sense there's the eagle um
so young player being weak in the end
game maybe
but we just watched a game of magnus
getting whooped in the end game by
alireza so i wouldn't really base my
strategy on that
so i feel like it's split
is this a real threat because if yes we
have to worry about it then we should
probably do like rookie to defend it
if it's not a real threat then we can
just develop the knight so which one is
it
all right i'm saying more in favor of
rook d8 yeah i feel like it is then also
c7
is under attack yes but
if not d6 take we're not gonna just
uh play rookies we're gonna go for the
bigger fish
yeah this is this is a very good way of
developing because
you see that it's like a you're bluffing
a little
actually that's not true because
bluffing um white was bluffing about the
pond
so black kind just called it and
you're just developing you're going for
actual knight and now white has to
figure out a way to stop it's rookie
eights does the k1 does not work
does anybody want to tell me why or q1
doesn't work
why not look after the e8
um i think this works too
but i think you're okay eats
you don't want to leave anything hanging
for future references
but it doesn't mean that it's not good
okay
just is a little bit more solid because
rookie one
now what do you want to do after rookie
one
is a pen so we would really want to use
that
i think it's pretty sure
queen c3 what if he just develops the
bishop then
i think this is also okay but is this
this is also fine black does hold
some advantage but this is even stronger
take take and just bring your knights
the bishop can't really go anywhere the
queen is kind of
just pretty useless here where's the
night going
not really no it's just going to chill
here for a minute
let's say you play
rugby one then i can eat over here
let's say you can't really defend this
well let's say you play queen h3 to
defend the pawn
now i'm gonna slowly slowly just double
up my rooks
well if you play rookie four then you
just get a shot of the white things
well bishop will go somewhere
take take
i kind of like this or even if you're
worried about that they can't just do
rookie five
i prefer rookie four because it keeps my
queen open
even if you don't go there actually yeah
this is
this is what makes the most sense quincy
turina bring in the knights
and eventually this even if you did now
i can eat over here
and i cannot push but my pieces are way
too active for just one pawn
actually i was wrong even if not one
pawn we we got the pawn back but my
pieces are way more active for the pawn
that we
gave a little earlier all right so
that's one thing to keep in mind
rookie one doesn't work so uh ali rizzo
wins for bishop v3 which was also did
not work
queen g4 was the only move that could
have tried to hold it
because if queen g4 you are trying to
you know defend over here
rookie five rookie one kind of puts up a
better fight
because now my rook is in a blocking my
queen too
but black still does have advantage so
still unpleasant all right so let's say
bishop e3 now what do we do
try to identify which one of your pieces
is the most
uh useless one and just
go from there
yeah knight c4
best one now bishop d4
should we move the queen or should they
block it
i mean why create a pen if you don't
have to
well because it's not just a pen you're
also doing a fork
[Music]
although if you play queen g6 is maybe
the idea of bishop c8
well i guess the bishop's on f3 so
that's not a huge right
ninety five makes the most sense if you
were to move this queen
that is okay but now opponent gets the
chance to
start breathing basically and it's not
you're the piece i mean you still have
advantage but
um we don't want opponent pieces to get
the chance to
untangle i guess that's a better word
but yeah that's that's a that's a big
problem right now
again black still does hold considerable
advantage
but um it's more annoying to go for a
knight t5
and you can't exactly take it because
that only just helps me
and if you don't take it you gotta move
the queen
no should i take it or should i do we
see anything better
is the night on e2 in that moment
yeah but um knight takes with check and
then
uh if he takes with the g pawn you play
queen g6 or
then you get knight i guess g3 right
well
actually yeah you're right you are kind
of getting the piece
knight f3 is the best one take and
uh queen g6 or queen g5 i think they're
equally good i don't really see any
difference
and um king h1 was played so what are
you thinking it's fun what do you think
is the idea for
whites playing i guess
yeah you want to try to create some
counter play
so what do you think is the best way to
block this idea
and just to quickly mention knight's g3
we'll just eat the rook
and something like queen g3 i can
i kind of just want to exchange this i
would just take this honestly
it's kind of it might not be the most
accurate one but i would take and i
would eat one of these pieces and
voila so kingish one we know what
white wants so how can we try to black
just block this
idea
well the knight is still pinned
so i guess you don't necessarily take it
right away
um
i was thinking queen takes on d5
um
queen defense is actually what happened
in the game that was a mistake
so here are kind of blue the advantage
because right now this is like
plus three at least but they they made a
mistake
also still kind of blows it where are
you trying planning to go with the queen
well not not here earlier ah uh
how does that help yeah
you'd still have to play this f6 to
block this
so yeah what do you guys think rook g1
is happening
how is how is it the how can we do the
best one to
stop it
yeah i i think chat is correct to want
to do f6
or bishop c8 but uh highlight bishop
f6 makes more sense if rook g1
now we can do this bishop c8
because if you take now i'll take over
here and the rook is under attack the
knight is under attack
rook g3 i can just eat over here you
take this
i really really want to eat this
yeah g6 makes the most sense
so i guess we're not actually winning
these positions uh not necessarily
but we have enough enough advantage to
to comfortably continue this game
there are too many weak pieces here
that's a perfect blocker yep
and i don't really see any good ideas
for white
i think the lack of ideas for white is
the biggest problem too
weak bonds and extra pawn another weak
pawn
anyways that would be a good way to win
but arnold made a mistake and he simply
took here
poof the whole advantage went away now
there's a little better
it's so fun how chess all the advantage
just goes poof
all right rg1 clear threads now you have
to play f6
you could consider g6 but then knight f4
and yeah f6 is the best one to do to try
and defend
knight f4 now like the fourth
alire is a bullet this is so much fun
for me
so let's see why to move what do you
think is the best move for white
how can you you have like a single move
to
keep advantage
what do you think that single move is
i want it to be rip takes g7 but i know
it's not why not
uh i mean you don't have a light square
bishop i feel like
i don't know tactically like looking for
tactics that's the first thing i look at
h8 and then
so it's more about which one gives you
the best chance
not necessarily um and then when you
realize that this is the one that gives
you the best chance then it's about
calculating it and um i i mean it
i understand it's a little weird but
rook g7
you have to take it that's the only
option rook g1
you can't really go to f7 because that's
going to
be very fun so you gotta
put this king on its rate and now the
one final piece that's
not working will join now this bishop is
pretty useless over here
knight g6 is happening and you can't
really stop it
and you're going to lose the queen
so this would actually give whites the
very
reasonable winning chance uh it's not
that black would be completely out of
the game
but um still this would give white the
best winning chance plus
two at least
so queen that's why queen d5 was wrong
because it gives district g7
if you were just going to play chill
moves like this that's perfectly fine i
can just come exchange my queen
and uh in the game white didn't choose
to exchange the queens and
he just kind of went for uh queen h6 so
now clear threats we got to defend it
rook f7 or rook e7 these two make the
most sense my rook is already doing
something here so i'm gonna let this
rook
be i'm just going to go for rook f7 and
now rook g3 what is the threat with rook
g3
what does white want
maybe what else
so what else do we do what else can we
think of
yeah thank you anonymous in the chat
knight that's five
yeah night israel is a big thing that
right now white wants
uh rookies for rxg1 is also another one
so queen c2 was played
and after
rook after taking on c2 knight h5
and boom knight f5 so black is already
much better right now so
that's uh yeah that's something that's
um not very pretty i do want to go back
to
death rook g7 and spend just a little
bit more time on it
but let's see how can uh black win this
let's say knight f6
now what do we do careful not to get
checkmated
i guess you could take it and then queen
takes
that is true uh taking you have to
consider what if queen takes so what if
coin takes
can we just yeah
yeah easy peasy if queen tags just
take this and take the queen voila
if rook g7 now what's well i mean we
have to take it
then take over here now what do we do
yeah now we have to come back and defend
this because if we didn't that's
that's literally the only move if not
rock g1 is also coming up
and that's the only move to win
and then queen g6 rox g1
now what
well if we take the queen the bishop
will take it and the knights will fall
oh yeah i didn't see you don't have
bishop
yeah so maybe let's take a minute and
think
what to do here
also from the chat any questions from
the earlier positions
because surprisingly this game was
faster than i expected it to be
i was curious why you played rogue g3
before playing knight h5
okay know the queen would take it or
take f uh f3 will check oh right
we'll go back and address it because the
game is almost over
here so uh let's see white wants my
queen
that's clear so how can we save this
taking is okay kind of blows a lot of
the advantage
so is there anything else that could um
that i could face this i looked at
rookie one
but i don't think it really accomplishes
it not really
then also maybe oh who
but the queen is defending your rook is
too hard
out of it yeah
anonymous you are too strong
i mean
so yeah okay now everybody in the chat
is saying it too
yeah so queen yeah does that work
yeah because after take just look here
king up check and the queen drops
yeah a lot of fun not necessarily mating
nets but
queen eating that no this was a fun game
and actually um
fliro just resigned here
because if you take it then black is
gonna have like an edbd advantage in the
end game that's not even gonna be worth
mentioning it
but that was a very um
short game so we have some extra time
let's go back and look at the
um earlier positions see if anybody has
any questions
so what do you guys think there was a
question on rook g3 i think
so here
anonymous he was already losing he
wasn't about missing or not
the only thing that he could have done
differently was this knight f4
here white had a serious chance of
getting pretty decent advantage
but white kind of messed it up they like
it was a move order problem
yeah knight of four you gotta bring the
queen back
kaboom move it check
actually can i just go over here
and um let's say another check
and well actually i can't move this
because there's that
so with that
maybe let's check over here on g4 king
h8
actually this is a very critical
position what do you guys think white
should do here because only one move
holds advantage the other ones kind of
give black chance to equalize
bakken is stuck good for you
being stuck is not fun
uh anonymous i don't know the story
behind it but
probably yeah that would make sense
uh okumu yeah we did that's like knight
f4 was the move that played
that was played in the real game with
knight um instead of
g7 but that's
that kind of blew up the advantage
completely so what to move
just one single move let's think about
it logically you want to eat my knight
i can't really touch my knights because
i would get tricky you want
you can do knight d3 but if you play
knight d3 i can still go for like c5 and
then you gotta move this bishop
and then i can bring this bishop back
black gets a lot of
initiative so we want to take over here
so white
what can white do to try to stop him
you can't exactly run with the knight so
any
tricky ideas
so how can we use this diagonal
um not really you don't really have
enough pieces to use it
so we want to be able to if you take
i want to be able to take back and give
you check so
how how can i organize that
giving check with the knight will not
help us nope sorry chad
sacrificing the bishop more like
blundering it no
d7 uh knight d7
still doesn't really do us that good
because we still have this check
or if you want to be too too cute we can
do this
i don't think it's dropping it
oh right but still bishop ca this is
still very annoying
so not that 97 not 97.
how about um oh
persians not spurious i think you have
the wrong square because queen f5
just the knight takes it but queen f4 is
the right one yeah
after queen f4 white simply wants to
if you take it they want to take back
and i think that's a
now that's a fairy tale that's how
yep that's how you give checkmate
but um yeah so queen f4 was would be the
best idea whoa you can give check first
here and
anyways you got to get this queen to f4
and
taking is not really possible and so
what else
and unfortunately right now black is
still quite busted
because next move i'm going to go knight
g4 and you're
you're checking stuff is not going to
work anymore f6 is very stuck
that's how white would win it if this
line happens
the structure zone only works because of
this idea of getting the queen to f4
so it makes sense that white didn't play
it if they didn't really see this queen
f4
last move so yeah it was a very
beautiful game because
um there was a lot of little tactics in
it that's white mist
black mist but overall black had a
better game
especially i really enjoyed the the
maneuvers that black was doing in the
opening i thought
i thought it was very crazy for how
black just like
started moving around with these two
knights
without um without any scared
scariness wait without being scared and
it was quite scary to just
like b6 here with the idea bishop a6 is
very mind-blowing so yeah
i really enjoyed this game and
uh i think the where white went wrong
was
with this idea and having this
pin it would make more sense to either
try to keep the queen
local in the king side or just unpin
yourself i think those would be the
better
choices so
troy boy i hope you will have lovely
dreams about magnus
this should be fun and i think
bach and is still google translating
good for you learning new words
all right guys i'm gonna call it a day
this was a very short game i enjoyed it
i got grocery shopping to do and a very
chunky cat to attend
all right this is very fun uh this is
our first
live in-person lesson and sent louis
after
16 months since last march yeah
so um if you are in saint louis please
make time to join us today we had people
joining us thank you
if you're not in san luis we'll get on a
plane
and if you can't do that well join us
live
here pretty much every day from now on
because there's going to be classes left
and right
and with that have a great fourth
weekend
[Music]
you